The volume of a cube
is equal to its length
times its width
times its height.
A cube with side x has length
x, width x, and height x.
So its volume is equal
to x times x times
x, or x to the third.
Shane takes a big cube of
butter with side length 5
from the fridge.
So I'm assuming-- well, they're
not giving us the units.
Maybe it's 5 centimeters.
With side length
5 from the fridge.
Maybe I'll go with
5 centimeters.
That seems reasonable.
Then he cuts out a little
cube of side length 2
from one of the
corners of the cube.
Write an expression
that describes
the volume of butter left.
So let's think about it.
The original volume of
butter that was-- they're
saying side length 5.
I'm visualizing it
as 5 centimeters.
Its volume is going
to be 5 times 5 times
5, which we could just write
as 5 to the third power.
And then he takes out a
little chunk from that.
And the volume that
he takes out is
the volume of that little cube.
And that little cube
has side length 2.
So its volume is going
to be 2 times 2 times 2.
Or another way of writing
that is 2 to the third power.
So it's going to be 5 to the
third minus 2 to the third.